they're not drumsticks they're crab
sticks just dumped in here top off
another bag of Alaskan crab no dates no
labels how are we supposed to run a
business when you've got no idea what's
in the freezers
what is down here my god it gets worse
look at it it's absolutely jam-packed
chicken after chicken after chicken my
big worries how much chicken does this
restaurant really need I mean they're
just bags of it not only that smell is
horrific oh my god
look at these bullets I've seen less
packs at an army base so the 50 packs of
meat and whoever's buying this needs to
be fired
now what worries me about this this is
one more fridge upstairs is that [ __ ]
pigeon
Oh God it's never-ending just when I
think I've seen enough
there's more look dad be composed soft
dead
unless the snails Oh
who is that man there's a road dead
Lobster that is disgusting
it's two hours into Chef Ramsay's
inspection Michael Valbuena and Jerry
arrive unaware of what Chef Ramsay is
doing and what he has uncovered morning
morning chef I just need you for two
minutes
who in the hell buys produce here who
who's responsible for that I am you are
[ __ ] pigeon what I'm trying to look
at are the profits the purchasing the
thousands of dollars waste these here
they came in yesterday that's dead some
little around here Jerry please and you
wonder why I don't like your source that
is a dead Lobster
[Music]
and the freshest thing in this kitchen
is that pigeon flying around and he's
lucky he's still alive bloody hell
that have you got up in yes yeah remotes
just for the front door ah it's for the
door
no we just had the exterminator you page
to the exterminator sure get your money
back okay that's not funny
I've got a generator outside you take
that now as a general manager do
something with it the mouse it was in
the entrances of Alton oh we always have
the exterminator once a month invention
nice hey show me we found that they said
the front door where well where's the
front door in your mind I came to the
door walked in there saw him bang right
there right do you have an iPhone are
you kidding me
what you thought I brought it in out of
my pocket I think you did are you are
you are you [ __ ] dreaming I arrived
the mouse was there never never here
never there was no not never known mouse
where right okay so we had the
exterminator last week they come on
regular occasions yes we have an issue
with mice that's why you have an
exterminator we don't have this almost
an exterminator comes in okay let's let
you know I do a little investigation
let's go
[Music]
it's wait where's that um II spoke to
the mouse in here no I've never seen one
you've never seen one good
except that one that was under the steam
table that looks bad cheap ones back
almost a year back he found a mouse in
the front door
I've never been so embarrassed and
humiliated in my life this is ridiculous
really ridiculous and saying
I never seen in myself perhaps we
planted that Mouse and you're suggesting
that I brought it in I was like hmm I
put it together like just for TV sake
maybe I wish you would talk a little bit
sense
[ __ ] the TV furnish your money where
your mouth is in front of your staff I
want to a meeting upstairs with you and
everybody knows and stuff it's my
successor all over this place we can
happen it can happen
Shelley two seconds please all of you
this is very very important
so I was telling seeing him like almost
like that so just look at James freak 2
seconds I walked in the front door a
mouse the mouse there to plan it I know
they told me but it's okay no it's not
okay it's got nothing to do with TV
nothing to do with your business in the
[ __ ] I am NOT gonna stand there and even
attempt to take that crap from you you
can take your restaurant and stick it I
am gone I'm out of it
you're out of here I'm out of here later
let's know it's over here is the cowboy
burger cowboy with a very spoon on top
look at the bun wedgie style
[Music]
[Music]
come on seriously $39 you'd expect a
decent Bunter
bland greasy cookie hell that is
straight for firing your fault well I
was shocked disappointed embarrassed huh
he flies up guys but one thing I have
that's a little different is in
Australian meat pie
the Australian meat pie is the number
one staple in Australia I have brought
them to America and Chef Ramsay will
absolutely love it
that's Ramsay's other words nothing like
it what do they like it
so this is the the Australian meat pie
the beef
[Music]
you know disgusting that Australian I
can [ __ ] off back to Australia with
pleasure
I've got raw doughy pastry on top and
saw the gooey stuff on the bottom one
word for this meow cat food job no
that's fine but you see sadly that look
honestly
how [ __ ] depressing is that are you
serious kid job please come look at the
four top please he got his fit now
missing the map of America son of these
cursed California with a little dark
spot is from the central Midwest and we
have Seattle we're here Pittsburgh
[Music]
[ __ ] flying Chanel did you taste it
if you got to stand out that mean it's
too hard
I'm not to pull okay so I see you had a
chance to taste the pork chop and now
what did you think
yeah dry like a mouthful of sand it's
drier than mr. Howard desert all right
even the Flies no longer interested okay
is there anything else you wanted me to
get for you or a wheel for that bike out
there that way I can get the [ __ ] out of
it
vegetarian
charge two seconds was a bone during a
teeny vegetarian tomato sauce
they put pork bones in it what the [ __ ]
she's vegetarian that's how we do it
every day
John is responsible for the methods that
we use to produce the food get me a job
urgently who says if you don't like it
leave this this is urgent now a lady
adjust found a pork bone in the rigors
feeding we're open to give the sauce
later we've always always added sausage
for serving ball burns in the sauce to a
vegetarian
that's how we prepare food for the last
40 years and don't see it being a
problem okay salsa [ __ ] vegetarian
it's the way we've always done our
business you can't start a vegetarian a
pork sauce
what the [ __ ] is going over there
[ __ ] enough have enough
your coffee will that make it better
we okay
waiting for the no what does he have
the most recent tasted
and next May 19
John
that would be sick in a box yeah yeah
lobster at the mushroom
like a medical assistance which allow me
to pull man 1 watch very possibly love
to tell please and you will laugh the
tail it's hot bright by you guys
throwing up he's in the bathroom sink
please show me exactly what you serve
that customer yeah please thank you
all right
your blasters ready
John come here seriously fishy Backus
family ammonia yeah be smaller and
that's what that man is just eaten
that's what releases a body stuff
decompose has been pulled apart and then
decompose that's what makes it bear
so just clarify something for me what
could possibly kill them kill someone
and whilst we're discussing this and
there's a man vomiting in the toilet now
I can't believe this is happening right
now
feels like [ __ ] to not achieve that
somebody's sick it's the first time
you've got your head out of the dough
but it's Johnny's responsibility no
matter what because John buys all the
product that we use yes please we call
an ambulance
hi this is South speaks or it Dunedin am
Korsak us was not killing well my worst
fears but anybody to get sick in my
restaurant there's a shot of something I
need a shot I need a shot of something I
got a guy Samedi I'm gonna give me
something give me quite a lot vodka
somebody came to your house and you
cooked them at dinner how would you feel
he started puking all over the place
a guy had some Lobster and he has a
reaction to it the gentlemen sit down oh
yes we got
needs to kill the cameras kill the
camera we beat this month and a half
good tips I don't mean tit
so there you I make out really reach the
two scared don't it
Wow $10 tip yeah yeah why not did you
think the girls deserve some tips
tonight no pick it hourly sir the
tipping you left the young lady server
the owner takes the tips then oh [ __ ] we
do oh my god
unfortunately the majority of the people
in Arizona think that if you come to our
restaurant that we're gonna yell at you
scream at you and throw you outside and
that is not who we are
is your first time and last time I'm
going to come back mother keep walking
mr. you can just keep watching levitates
coming you want to wait you wait don't
you give me a break this is you guys I
make
you [ __ ] you all think then you
can come in here and say these things
are you kidding me this is ridiculous